La guerra en Ucrania es un auténtico drama.
Ojo, no solo para los ucranianos, que son,
por supuesto, las víctimas de una invasión
criminal, sino también para la propia Rusia,
por mucho que el régimen de Putin se esfuerce
en hacer creer lo contrario.
A las pérdidas económicas, de las cuales
ya os hemos hablado hace no mucho tiempo aquí,
en VisualPolitik y también en nuestro boletín
exclusivo de Patreon, hay que sumarle las
pérdidas militares, que son todavía mucho
más importantes.
En el momento en el que preparamos este vídeo,
desde que diera comienza la guerra, Rusia
ha tenido según los cálculos occidentales
casi 200.000 bajas desde que empezó la guerra,
entre soldados muertos o incapaces de combatir
por haber sido heridos.
Para que os hagáis una idea, esto serían
OCHO VECES [enfatizar] más bajas en un solo
año de guerra que todas las que tuvo Estados
Unidos en sus dos décadas en Afganistán.
Ocho veces más. Casi nada.
Por supuesto, además, muchos de esos soldados
tendrán secuelas físicas y psicológicas
de por vida.
Sin embargo, no, esto no parece que esté
siendo un motivo que haga que en el Kremlin
se replantee la guerra. ¿Y sabéis qué?
La verdad es que no debería sorprendernos
demasiado.
(Históricamente, la tradición militar rusa
no ha sido precisamente conocida por valorar
y proteger la vida de sus soldados. Bien por
carecer de esa sensibilidad o por falta de
medios, las guerras han sólido ser un picadero
de carne para Moscú.
Un ejemplo lo tenemos en la Segunda Guerra
Mundial, en la que murieron más de ocho millones
de soldados soviéticos, de todos ellos más
de seis millones y medio fueron rusos.
Y sí, es cierto, la Rusia de Putin no es
la Unión Soviética, pero la guerra de Ucrania
nos ha demostrado que en la práctica esa
mentalidad no ha cambiado demasiado. Rusia
sigue dispuesta a pagar elevadísimos costes
humanos con tal de perseguir sus objetivos
militares.)
Todo esto además viene favorecido por la
falta de oposición política y una ciudadanía
apática, sometida durante años a las intensas
campañas de propaganda del régimen. Con
lo que es poco probable que la pérdida de
vidas sea un gran impedimento para Putin.
De hecho, muchos analistas creen que podría
soportar todavía varios cientos de miles
de bajas más en Ucrania sin que el régimen
se viera realmente comprometido.
Y claro, esto nos lleva directamente a una
pregunta… Si esto es así, ¿de qué forma
se puede detener a Rusia en el campo de batalla
político y militar? ¿Cuál es su punto débil
si las bajas no parecen pasarle demasiada
factura a Putin?
Pues bien, la clave está precisamente en
su armamento. En cosas como los tanques, la
artillería o la aviación.
Ya puedes tener muchos hombres listos para
mandarlos al frente, que si no están bien
equipados el resultado puede ser desastroso.
Especialmente si enfrente tienen armas relativamente
modernos.
Y no, no estamos hablando de coger y empezar
a bombardear, o mejor dicho, hacer explotar,
a diestro y siniestro, fábricas de armamento
rusas. Para nada.
En este vídeo os vamos a cómo se está reduciendo
exactamente la capacidad militar rusa, os
contaremos cómo las sanciones están afectando
a la industria militar.
Así que, sin más preámbulo, arranquemos.
T1 (DESARMANDO AL GIGANTE)
No es ningún secreto, las pérdidas de hardware
militar ruso en Ucrania están siendo devastadoras
para el que se creía que era el segundo ejército
más poderoso del planeta.
Mientras que a Ucrania le suplen un montón
de países tanto armas como municiones, Rusia
está, hasta ahora, prácticamente sola en
esta guerra.
Y os voy a dar unos datos para que os hagáis
a la idea de lo que estamos hablando.
Para mediados de diciembre, según el secretario
de Defensa del Reino Unido Rusia había perdido
4.500 blindados, de ellos 1.800 serían tanques.
Luego, además, 63 aviones, 70 helicópteros,
150 drones, 12 buques de guerra y más de
600 sistemas de artillería.
Asimismo, ha llegado a disparar hasta 20.000
proyectiles por día y el lanzamiento de misiles
de precisión ha estado muy por encima de
su capacidad de producción.
Algo que, por cierto, en cierto modo también
ha sucedido en ocasiones con los aliados de
Ucrania.
(Ucrania está quemando munición más rápido
de lo que EE.UU. y la OTAN puede producirla
- CNN)
La diferencia es que no solo las fábricas
de Estados Unidos y del resto de países de
la OTAN pueden proporcionar armas o municiones
a Ucrania, también se están comprando suministros
en otros países para luego enviárselos al
ejército ucraniano. Es evidente que la chequera
occidental muy grande… Como támbién lo
puede ser su capacidad industrial en relativamente
poco tiempo.
Sin embargo, los rusos no tienen hoy por hoy
esa capacidad, y, desde luego, nadide - o
nadie serio - espera que la vayan a tener
en el futuro.
De hecho, su capacidad de fabricar equipamiento
militar se ha degradado mucho en los últimos
meses, en parte gracias a las sanciones internacionales,
y este, amigos, amigas, en un elemento que
puede llegar a resultar clave.
Muchos cargos militares y analistas occidentales
creen que si Rusia no consigue mantener su
industria militar en funcionamiento, la guerra
podría terminar por falta de armas, con el
consiguiente bochorno para Putin que podría
significar su propio final.
Ahora bien, ¿es esta estrategia es realista?
¿Tiene Rusia las de ganar o las de perder
ante una guerra de desgaste? En el Kremlin
parecen pensar que lo primero, pero, ¿realmente
es así?
Pues veréis, hay al menos dos grandes motivos
para pensar que Rusia lo va a tener extremadamente
difícil en los próximos meses para suplir
de armas su campaña militar. Mucho más incluso
de lo que lo ha tenido hasta ahora.
¿El primero? Las restricciones a las exportaciones
a Rusia.
Como ya os hemos contado en vídeos pasados
aquí, en VisualPolitik, tanto la industria
civil como la industria militar rusas son
ineficientes y, en general, están tecnológicamente
desfasadas y son dependientes de otros países.
Por este motivo, la prohibición de exportar
elementos clave para la industria rusa ha
sido una de las principales puntas de lanza
de la estrategia occidental.
(Hablamos no solo de tecnologías puramente
militares, sino, sobre todo, de los llamados
equipos de doble uso.
Hablamos de tecnología de vanguardia que
no son puramente militares pero podría usarse
con ese fin, como por ejemplo semiconductores
avanzados, ópticas y sensores o incluso software.)
Este tipo de sanciones están provocando pérdidas
en la producción por falta de insumos, lo
cual no solo redunda en una menor capacidad
de producción de unidades de combate.
También hace que las unidades que salen de
fábrica, bien sean nuevas o reacondicionadas,
lo hagan con tecnología mucho más básica.
¿Queréis ejemplos? Fijaos.
(Plan de tanques de Rusia: Coges un T-62 de
60 años de antigüedad, le instalas nuevas
ópticas, y le mandas a Ucrania para que lo
exploten
Mientras sacan hasta 800 T-62 del almacenamiento
de largo plazo, el fabricante de tanques ruso
Uralvagonzavod está equipando algunos de
ellos con la mira térmica analógica [1PN96MT-02]
que es una generación más nueva que la mira
anterior del T-62. - Forbes)
Ojo, tanques de principios de los 60, les
ponen una nueva mira y un par de cosillas
más, y ya, restyling completado, para Ucrania.
Es un plan de tres años de duración, pero
los que vayan teniendo listos irán para Ucrania
a la desesperada.
Pero eso no es todo, a los tanques más modernos,
como los T-80 o T-14 Armata, que, supuestamente,
son la joya de la corona del ejército ruso,
también les están poniendo esas mismas ópticas
que son mucho menos avanzadas que las que
tenían originalmente.
Y es que, ¿sabéis de dónde procedían,
por ejemplo, la mayoría de esas miras térmicas
y ópticas avanzadas que se equipaban con
orgullo en los tanques rusos? Pues, sí exacto,
no eran originarias de Rusia ni mucho menos,
sino que procedían de países occidentales
o de su órbita, como Japón en el caso de
algunas ópticas o Francia, entre muchos otros.
(Según documentos clasificados obtenidos
por la organización francesa de periodismo
de investigación Disclose, las e mpresas
Thales y Safran habrían suministrado al ejército
ruso tecnologías militares occidentales muy
avanzadas.
Hablamos por ejemplo de ópticas modernas
para más de 1.000 tanques, así como sistemas
de navegación TACAN para 60 Sukhoi-30 y detectores
infrarrojos para aviones de combate. También
habrían suministrado sistemas de mira para
helicópteros Kamov-52.
Algunas de estas tecnologías habrían sido
entregadas por empresas francesas a Rusia
hasta el año 2020, es decir, hasta mucho
después de la invasión de Crimea y el Donbás
de 2014.)
Estos son solo algunos ejemplos, pero la realidad
es que la industria militar rusa es muy dependiente
de componentes occidentales de todo tipo en
cuanto quieren fabricar algo con una cierta
complejidad tecnológica.
Por ejemplo, según el think tank británico
de defensa y seguridad RUSI, los giroscopios
de fibra óptica que equipan los misiles guiados
de 300 mm utilizados en los lanzadores Tornado-S
eran de fabricación estadounidense.
O, tenemos también, el caso de los vehículos
militares del fabricante KAMAZ, que ha tenido
que detener la producción de todas sus plataformas
modernas de uso militar porque los inyectores
de combustible eran de la marca alemana Bosch.
Incluso el sistema de defensa aérea ruso
TOR-M2, uno de los más potentes de corto
alcance, tiene componentes británicos que
controlan el radar de la plataforma.
Es decir, en resumidas cuenta, que en cuanto
nos vamos a armas un poco sofisticadas, que
podrían en cierto modo competir con el armamento
occidental, prácticamente ninguna es 100%
rusa.
Prácticamente, todas tienen algún componente
o tecnología de países que ahora ya no se
la proporcionan.
E
Y como podréis imaginar, esto les obliga,
o bien a no poder fabricar estas unidades,
o bien a buscar sustitutos para esos componentes.
Sustitutos mucho más anticuados, lo que reduce
enormemente sus capacidades de combate.
Y claro, eso en última instancia debilita
al ejército de Putin en su conjunto.
En general, se calcula que las sanciones internacionales
contra Rusia en las que están directamente
implicados más de 30 países han desplomado
sus importaciones en más de un 40 por ciento
en 2022.
Y eso es teniendo en cuenta las sanciones
posteriores al 24 de febrero de 2022…
Porque luego, también están las que se impusieron
tras la invasión de Crimea y el Donbass.
Sanciones que se orientaron sobre todo a la
compra de equipos y suministros militares.
Sanciones que no le han permitido a Rusia
producir tanto armamento ni modernizar al
ritmo esperado sus fuerzas armadas.
[¿Quizás Putin pensaba que ocupar territorio
ucraniano no iba a tener ninguna consecuencia?
En fin, quién sabe…]
Por ejemplo, Rusia tenía un acuerdo de compra
de cuatro buques de asalto anfibio Mistral
con Francia que fue cancelado tras estos acontecimientos.
Pero al margen de los miembros de la OTAN,
otros países no sancionadores también han
reducido últimamente su comercio con Rusia
de forma voluntaria para no tener consecuencias
negativas en los mercados occidentales, que,
evidentemente, son mucho más importantes
que el ruso.
Y esto no acaba aquí, para nada. Hay al menos
otro motivo para pensar que Rusia lo va a
tener muy difícil para producir armas al
ritmo al que las está usando en la guerra.
Y es simple y llanamente el factor económico
puro y duro.
Pensadlo bien, mantener a flote la capacidad
militar en una guerra que dura ya más de
un año y en la que prácticamente estás
solo, sin apoyo de nadie más, es algo que
cuesta mucho, muchísimo dinero.
Y las sanciones, evidentemente, no le han
venido nada bien a la economía rusa.
Obviamente, una guerra no es algo barato,
y no olvidemos que Rusia, por muy grande que
sea, no deja de tener un PIB per cápita similar
al de países como Argentina o Rumanía.
El caso es que aunque los datos oficiales
sobre el coste de la invasión para Rusia
están clasificados, se estima que el presupuesto
militar superó ampliamente el 5 por ciento
del PIB en 2022, alcanzando así un récord
no visto desde los tiempos de la Unión Soviética.
Podemos estar hablando fácilmente de unos
95.000 millones de dólares, y esto sería
una desviación respecto al presupuesto proyectado
para 2022 de más del 40 por ciento.
Queridos amigos, la guerra no ha sido tan
corta como esperaban, y por tanto tampoco
tan “barata”.
Ahora bien, ¿en qué parte entran en juego
las sanciones en esta historia?
Pues, básicamente, las sanciones económicas
como el fin de la importación de gas o el
tope de precio al petróleo ruso, entre otras,
están empezando a impactar considerablemente
en las cuentas públicas de Rusia.
Por ejemplo, según los datos, ojo, del propio
gobierno ruso, el déficit federal en los
dos primeros meses del año asciende a 2,6
billones de rublos - unos 34.100 millones
de USD. Esta cifra supone el 88% de todo el
déficit previsto por el gobierno ruso para
el 2023.
De esta forma, según las estimaciones de
Escuela de Economía de Kiev y varios analistas
el déficit real en 2023 será tres o cuatro
veces mayor que en 2022. Al ritmo actual,
el gobierno consumirá por completo el Fondo
Nacional Ruso de Inversión (NWF) antes de
finalizar el año. Este es el fondo que supuestamente
tenía que asegurar la capacidad económica
del gobierno ante situaciones extraordinarias…
Como la guerra de Ucrania. Hablamos de unos
150 mil millones de dólares a comienzos de
2023 que podrían consumirse en apenas unos
meses.
A partir de ese momento los problemas para
Moscú podrían multiplicarse porque básicamente
solo tendría dos opciones para mantener el
esfuerzo de guerra:
O financiar la guerra con emisión de deuda
pública en el mercado financiero local, lo
que incrementará los tipos de interés y
el propio déficit del gobierno.
O monetizar deuda con emisiones del banco
central, lo que podría disparar la inflación.
Y es que, queridos amigos, amigas, los ingresos
del gobierno ruso por las ventas de petróleo
y gas durante el arranque del 2023 se redujeron
un 46% respecto al mismo periodo del 2022.
Y eso no es todo. El resto de ingresos no
ligados a los hidrocarburos también se están
desplomando.
Las cosas no marchan bien.
( Esta situación está obligando al Kremlin
a incluir dentro de los presupuestos de las
regiones la compra de equipamiento militar.
Es decir, que los gobiernos locales y regionales
han perdido no solo poder, sino también recursos,
ya que parte de su presupuesto ahora se gasta
en defensa. Para que os hagáis una idea,
los gastos del Estado ruso fueron un 58 por
ciento más altos en enero de 2023 que en
el mismo mes de 2022, y eso según datos oficiales.)
Evidentemente, cuanto más esfuerzo financiero
tenga que hacer el Estado ruso para financiar
su guerra, más dificultades tendrá para
hacerlo.
Por eso, las sanciones económicas, al margen
de los efectos que puedan tener sobre otros
campos como la opinión pública y demás,
también tienen un impacto en la capacidad
militar.
Ahora bien, no estaríamos contandoos toda
la historia si pasásemos por alto cómo la
industria de defensa rusa y el propio Estado
se han ido adaptando a todas estas circunstancias
Y es que, evidentemente, cuando te imponen
sanciones te las intentas saltar. Y, por supuesto,
el caso de Rusia no es diferente.
Ahora bien, ¿hasta que punto lo están logrando?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T2 (INNOVAR PARA MATAR)
No os vamos a engañar… Los rusos están
demostrando cierta capacidad para saltarse
algunas de las sanciones internacionales impuestas
y así poder seguir con su campaña criminal
en Ucrania.
Sin embargo, ya os adelanto que esto más
que medidas efectivas son solo una manera
de ganar tiempo.
Y es que, veréis, Moscú está adquiriendo
semiconductores y microchips, así como otros
componentes de alta tecnología, en teoría
de uso civil, a través de países no adheridos
a las sanciones o con imposición de sanciones
menos duras como China, Kazajistán o Turquía.
Eso sí, mediante esta vía de importación
está logrando importar muchos menos productos
tecnológicos que antes, aunque algunos de
ellos tengan componentes occidentales a los
que ahora no tendrán acceso de forma directa.
En todo caso, ni siquiera podemos hablar de
que las sanciones no estén funcionando, porque
es evidente con todo lo que os hemos contado
que el tejido industrial ruso está muy lejos
de sus mejores días.
¿Producen? Sí, la industria militar ruso
producir produce, pero equipos mucho menos
avanzado que antes de la invasión.
(De hecho, algunas de las evidencias que hacen
pensar que Rusia todavía consigue componentes
para fabricar algunas armas avanzadas se han
conseguido en la propia Ucrania.
Por ejemplo, el análisis de los restos de
algunos misiles de precisión Kh-101 rusos
lanzados contra Kyiv recientemente han revelado
que fueron fabricados entre septiembre y octubre
de 2022.
Es decir, Rusia puede seguir fabricando armamento
avanzado aunque no en la cantidad y calidad
necesaria para enfrentarse a todo el armamento
occidental que está llegando a Ucrania, incluidos
por primera vez tanques relativamente modernos
como los Leopard.)
Para que os hagáis una idea del decrépito
estado de sus almacenes armamentísticos,
Rusia ya ha empezado a disparar misiles fabricados
en la época soviética.
Y esto se sabe porque las armas rusas, en
especial los misiles, lanzados contra Ucrania
se analizan en la medida de lo posible.
Por ejemplo, en enero de este año 2023, se
analizó un misil lanzado contra la ciudad
de Dnipro y resultó ser un Kh-22, cuya producción
empezó en el año 1962, y que son terriblemente
imprecisos.
De hecho, terminó impactando contra un edificio
de viviendas matando a decenas de personas.
(El edificio residencial en Dnipro fue alcanzado
por un misil Kh-22, que no puede ser derribado
por la defensa aérea ucraniana - Centro Militar
de Ucrania)
En fin, de locos.
Pero todavía hay algo más. Otro de los ejemplos
sobre cómo Rusia trata de evadir las sanciones
que afectan a su capacidad militar lo tenemos
en la importación de los famosos drones iraníes
de los que tanto se ha hablado.
Aunque no ha sido el único caso. También
han importado tanques y blindados de Bielorrusia
y se cree que municiones de artillería de
Corea del Norte. En fin, buscando ayuda en
lo mejor de cada casa.
Ahora bien, llegados a este punto, ¿qué
podemos aprender de la experiencia de más
de un año ya de guerra y de todas las sanciones
aplicadas contra Rusia?
Pues principalmente la lección es una: las
sanciones no pueden ser la única vía para
desgastar a Moscú, porque su efecto llegará
sobre todo en el medio y largo plazo. Así
que no servirían de nada sin el constante
apoyo militar a Ucrania en forma de entregas
de armamento.
Si los ucranianos no tienen la fuerza necesaria
para multiplicar el coste para Rusia en el
frente, no solo en vidas sino sobre todo en
armas, entonces es probable que Moscú no
tuviera tantos problemas para alargar su campaña
militar.
Y sí, evidentemente, esto desgastaría todavía
más a Ucrania, que en 2022 registró un gasto
militar aproximado del 32,5 por ciento de
su PIB, según el propio gobierno ucraniano.
Y sí, también nos desgastaría más a los
demás, porque alargaría la guerra.
Sin embargo, llegados a este punto la pregunta
clave es para ti; después de todo lo que
hemos visto, ¿crees que las sanciones a Rusia
están surtiendo efecto en el campo militar?
¿Deberíamos incrementar la entrega de armas
a Ucrania todavía más para acelerar el desgaste
ruso?
Como siempre, déjanos tu opinión aquí abajo,
en los comentarios. Y, si te ha gustado este
vídeo, no olvides darle like y suscribirte
al canal para no perderte ninguna novedad.
Y recuerda, puedes apoyarnos a través de
nuestra página de Patreon para poder seguir
creciendo y mejorando. Os dejamos el link
abajo en la descripción.
Una vez más, muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.